let's talk about the apocalypse we
haven't talked about the story before we
have it here uh would you take out a
loan to buy this week's groceries
americans are increasingly turning to
buy now pay later services for food and
other everyday essentials and there are
signs that the practice is putting some
in deep debt so um
i just want to say
if you don't have emergency food
supplies
i think you're probably in a bad spot
and um you know not everybody can buy
them because you know we we normally
shout at safeandreadymeals.com
and it's like two or three hundred bucks
for uh for a month supply now it used to
be like 100 something inflation's
through the roof
we ordered uh we ordered some food
we had some takeout got delivered and it
was like three people eating it was like
almost 100 bucks it's like a local diner
and we were just like what did we get
like how did
bite inflation people people really just
are frogs in a pot boiling as all this
stuff happens i just want to stress
when msnbc says we're in a civil war the
president comes out and says half the
country are extreme threats
and people are taking out loans to buy
food please pay attention to what's
going on because this is
extreme
extreme and i'm gonna say this too
i've actually been looking at uh
properties in other countries already no
problem saying that notably i will say
el salvador sounds really awesome with
the bitcoin stuff they're doing so i've
been looking at el salvador for a while
but
i want to stay in the united states and
make sure we can do what we can to
preserve our culture and preserve this
country
in the event that um
let's just say catastrophic defeat
defeats to the point of executions or
something
then i'm like okay i'm going to get away
from this place but i also want to point
out
as i've mentioned before
there are points throughout history
where we've seen people flee countries
before it got to the point where there
are mass executions and there are many
countries where this has happened where
their people have been genocided in
various ways
so
seeing all of this i'm not saying that
anytime soon anything like that's going
to happen i'm saying that
i'm going to buy a van and go live down
by the river and get ready to bug out
because it's getting insane people
taking out loans to buy groceries you
know you have to realize that means
something really bad is about to break i
took out loans in 2003 to buy groceries
after college for a couple years that
was a rough rough point in my life but i
was making 12 bucks an hour is right
after 9 11 tough to get a job 12 bucks
an hour was yeah but for me but i still
had to take out a couple hundred bucks a
month for groceries and food benefits
exist but this is uh uh americans are
increasingly turning into to to taking
out loans to buy groceries did you guys
see the chengdu riots i don't know if
you call them riots but the lockdown
they're locking down oh yeah 20 million
people and people are just storming in
and grabbing whatever they can chaos
there's videos of it people are like
grabbing groceries and pouring giant
amounts of rice this is a this is a big
uh
issue in china with with these lockdowns
and and when you run out of food in
china particularly if you're of a
certain age you remember mao's
great experiment and socialism the great
leap forward when
when millions of people starve to death
so not having food in china is the
ultimate insult the ultimate moment when
you freak out and say i'm going to do
whatever it takes i might die in the
process of disobeying my government but
i have to have food because they
remember what it was like to slowly
starve to death
um but but on the inflation thing like
this this is unfortunately um a very
predictable result of spending six seven
eight trillion i can't keep track
anymore how much money we spent that we
didn't have well not just that the money
supply was expanded by what 16 trillion
yeah it's all financed
they basically printed the money and
they have very more exotic ways than
actually running a printing press but
this is all fake money and it's the
ultimate transfer
from
working people people that have money in
their wallets money in their savings
accounts people that have to buy
groceries
they
pay
while rich people but the the the
connected the political insiders and not
just politicians but but when you when
you print all this money there's
injection points in the economy and who
are those the banksters yeah
so that you have this huge wealth
transfer from the poor to the rich
and this is part of bidenomics
and one of the reasons why he did that
speech
out of desperation is that people are
taking out loans to buy their groceries
can we just well i love pulling up the
m1 money stock here can i just show you
guys uh
something isn't right oh because uh bam
that's when the twelve trillion dollar
increase because savings were converted
to checking accounts basically but look
what that they did that to mask what was
coming right after that influx of
savings is that gigantic angle
was right here increase yes that went
from like i mean that's like a like what
a three a three times it probably went
from like a 20 percent growth that's
like five times so like a 78 percent
gain it's like five yeah money supply
increased by 500 percent this is what uh
thomas massey called the cheese and the
trap when they started giving out those
those relatively modest checks like
every time we passed another trillion
dollar bill just a small fraction of it
actually went to people
but we're now paying for that and all of
those people that got those checks are
getting utterly screwed by that spike
right there have you guys been paying
attention to like food costs and stuff
like that oh it's insane no it's been
getting crazier and crazier i remember
it was a year ago and i was like i went
to the grocery store and it was 600 and
i was shocked it's like now it's eight
hundred dollars
pork is through the roof gotta get that
bacon man
it's getting more expensive but we have
our own chickens
so you know they they bop about do their
chicken business and then lay eggs and
we eat them so i don't got to worry
about the cost of eggs that's great i
think the problem with leaving the u.s
is that
as the people who fled cuba i think
during trump's tenure got up on on stage
were able to say there is nowhere else
to go in el salvador sounds great and
portugal sounds good to me i've been
looking at portugal it turns out a lot
of californians have been moving there
so there's no hope there
this is really the last place to go and
i don't know brazil's are but you know
the issue is that if the us if the if
the us does falter that's the reserve
currency it's going to be a wild ride
so you got to wonder what happens like
what actually you know matt what are
your thoughts what happens let's say
let's say the u.s just erupts biden
comes out tomorrow and he's like i think
it's time to to put an end to this manga
and he starts arresting every trump
supporter and then you'd stop because
sappo's kicking doors and then also the
economy collapses the u.s dollar is
kicked up out of the countries what
happens well like you're thinking about
escaping to latin america the most
stable economies in latin america are
are dollarized so they've they've linked
their currency bitcoin
and el salvador bitcoin yes so i'm going
to go back to blockchain is
that's the only solution to all of our
problems because because i really think
it is and there's a reason why
um they're going after odyssey
they're going after bitcoin they're
going after blockchain
um they hate this stuff because of the
very definition it's not controlled um
the alternative to this economic
collapse is going to be this technology
that that makes us independent of
government um it's easier said than done
but what what happens if the dollar
is no longer the reserve currency let's
say tomorrow they're just like dollars
done
people that hold dollars are are screwed
so these central and south american
countries that are dollarized they're
all just belly up yeah well they they
eventually
will
do what they did in venezuela where the
currency is completely worthless and you
know every every couple weeks they pass
a massive increase in the minimum wage
but it doesn't mean anything because
they're their money's not worth anything
um uh hyperinflation
is
the logical result of of this kind of
stuff that the reason it hasn't happened
in the united states is that we are
tremendously wealthy and and we have we
have things that no latin american
country has in terms of of physical
assets and wealth and and the resilience
of our infrastructure i'm actually
surprised that that we haven't gotten
that point already
and you realize that for all of the the
darkness and the things that the
government has tried to do to stop the
economy
there's a lot of entrepreneurship in our
country there's a lot of innovation
there's a lot of people that work their
butts off to make sure that there still
is food on the on the grocery store
shelves i thought it would be worse
but yeah yeah uh it's supposed to get
really bad in the next few months but
it's supposed to get really bad a year
after a year a year from now or so yeah
so they're saying the fall harvest is
going to be brutal but then next year is
where it really gets scary
yeah there's there's a there's a
cascading effect on all this stuff
because you you have you have the green
agenda you have
energy shortages
you have
all
of the farmers and truckers and the
whole distribution chain think about the
millions of people between you
and your next meal that you don't know
you don't know anything about these guys
um they have all been affected by what
we've done over the last two years
and and the question is did we break the
supply chain
or is it resilient and and i've been
impressed by the resiliency of it but um
one piece in that in infinitely complex
puzzle
shuts things down
and and maybe it's energy the most
obvious thing but it could be anything
and we don't even understand what it is
that sounded sad
killing us i thought that was you were
like the optimistic i'm gonna white pill
you guys well i i was though because
like i was 20 minutes ago you can go you
can go read the stuff that i was writing
in 2020 about the supply chain and
predicting like um these stupid idiots
don't understand
how beautiful and complex this thing is
and if you decide that that guy can't go
to work but that guy has to go to work
well that guy that has to go to work is
dependent on the other guys that aren't
allowed to go to work
i expected this stuff to hit in 2020
2021
there's obviously a an impact now i
think
that people could easily fix these
problems if the government stopped
helping
i don't i think the government is
helping their ideology i think the the
climate change zealots are like it's
time to push people down
i think look you only need to listen to
the words they say bill gates thinks
there's too many people what do you do
when there's too many deer in an area
you call the deer
so why should i assume
that when these powerful global elites
are coming out saying we're
overpopulated the planet's going to
going to implode and you know in in five
ten years and there needs to be less
people
you you it's it's at that at that point
it's more conspiratory in my opinion to
assume they don't want people to die
yeah i'm not saying bill gates is going
around trying to kill people or anything
like that i'm saying they probably wish
it was happening at the very least yeah
well um if you're going to replace my
steak with bugs
they might succeed did you hear the
story about the thermostats where people
couldn't change the thermostats or the
locked out colorado and they were like
you opted into this program it's your
fault because what will happen is you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna get your
your gas turned on or your heating
turned on and then i say do you want to
do you want to sign up for our energy
saver program it'll save you a hundred
bucks a year and they'll go what do i do
nothing we just check the box and then
you get 100 bucks off and they go
cool sure they don't read it they have
no idea sure then it's 90 degrees
outside and they're like why can't i
change the temperature and they're like
you agreed to this dave that's what you
want very much like no i didn't no one
told me
so that's the future man you're going to
live in a pod you're going to eat the
bugs
that's the gag you know i i was talking
about i did this bit on twitter where i
said
it's it's 99 degrees in your house so
you go to your thermostat but you find
you find you're locked out and it says
you know emergency energy emergency
governor's orders so you decide to go
take a drive and and open the windows
you go to your electric car and it says
minimal charge driving not available
governor's orders you think uh so you
figure i'm gonna go walk down to the
park and as you're walking down there's
a guy standing at a checkpoint and he
says sir you need your card if you're
gonna come through this checkpoint and
you're like but my phone's dead because
i couldn't charge my phone sir you don't
have a qr card you can't come through
and then you're like look man i just
want to go to the park and then he pulls
out a cattle prod
and that's where the electricity went i
feel like that's china today you're
right it is i know i'm not
yeah that's where we'll be soon just
like china and then so then after you
get tased you get up you walk back to
your house
sit next to your pod home reach in and
grab a bag of crickets to munch on and
wait for the temperature to drop what do
you think is the resistant
like way around that
i don't know
farm chickens see i don't i don't
chickens eat crickets
chickens you eat chickens you know what
i mean that's what i'm talking about
it's all about chickens that's true
everything goes back to chicks
you know goats are pretty cool goats are
good people they're good you know cows
are all right cows are chill and you
know and cows it's only a couple years
so you can eat the whole thing you know
what i mean so you just kind of keep
making more of them they grass there's a
lot of grass grass everywhere you know
in fact we got so much grass we got to
pay a guy to take it from us we have
like when you have big acreage the
farmers come and just take it all for
you they bail it all up and they're like
it's a couple hundred bucks for us we
need cats eat it and they take it and
you know how about we just get some
goats then the goats eat the grass and
the goats give us more goats and we eat
the goats there you go why the chickens
yeah goats also give you milk which i
remember milking when i was growing up i
wanted to say they've been pushing this
energy plan in maryland for a while now
for over a year and i think that people
are going for it because it's going to
save them money and times are so hard
they're literally taking out loans so
they can get groceries it makes sense to
me you guys ever see that bit i can't
remember who did it where he's like a
get-rich-quick scheme and he's like you
put seeds in the dirt
put some water on it the food just grows
right under the ground you can sell it
you sell to people to give you money for
it just comes right out of the ground
it's like people really don't like
people in cities really don't understand
these concepts
i mean some people might be thinking oh
come on of course people understand
farming no dude kyle kalinski was on a
plane and he took a picture out the
window at a bunch of farms said i wonder
why it looks like that and people were
like bro
dude
come on what is that circle is that an
alien thing yeah he's having like this
really insane like did you guys ever
notice this so weird i'm looking at
farms dude that's where food comes from
the article that we've been looking at
before referenced um buy now pay later
services and i'm thinking of like after
pay and i think that comes into you know
you can pay
40 for the shirt or you can make four
payments of 10 for the shirt and i think
some of that comes into our we don't
like to deal with the consequences of
our actions mentality that a lot of
culture have you know
there's instant gratification and
there's uh delayed repercussion with
that kind of strategy and i think it
makes people divorce from the reality of
the impact they're having on their own
personal finances obviously inflation is
a huge deal but i think we're also
trying to find ways to not feel it and
it's creating larger problems down the
line i think it's time to move out to
the middle of nowhere
you know before we moved out to here
west virginia we were looking at montana
but montana is actually really expensive
like comparably expensive to being so
it's like you got to find the happy
medium where you're close to a city but
far enough away to where it's actually
cheaper but you have an airport looked
at wyoming i'd rather be up in a big
mountain somewhere with a satellite dish
but you just it's impossible to run a
business and fly guests in and things
like that plus there's no fuel and food
it's really it's a lot harder to come by
but uh surprisingly the property there
is comparably expensive you know so
we're all moving off the grid
i mean
yeah aren't you on capitol hill i mean
the new the freedom stand we're setting
up is is going to be off the grid it's i
mean it's on the grid because we don't
we're not we're not trying to separate
ourselves from the grid for some
political point but we have the
capabilities of operating independently
with solar with weld water solar systems
and
you know electric cars electric bikes we
can charge them up with solar power and
massive batteries we're good to go yeah
you got to be independent and then uh we
have over there we have like 18 roosters
i think now
gotta start eating them
yeah chris doesn't want to eat him
though he's he'd rather let him live and
just be free and i'm like but then the
fox eats them dude that's not fair i
want to eat them you know
but he doesn't want to eat them
chicago upbringing you guys aren't ready
i'm ready these chickens some of them
are dicks you know like you know we got
some some chickens that are just mean
and nasty their food as far as i'm
concerned the ones that are really nice
we'll let them keep laying their eggs
and have babies and you know live a good
healthy life but you know you can't you
can't wait too long until you eat them
because then they get nasty and and the
roosters are hard to eat anyway they're
rubbery but you just gotta put them in a
pressure cooker and cook them over a
nightmare rooster stew or something like
that do you have recipes
no no i don't you know can we make a
chicken cookbook though i feel like that
would be a tim cass product i think it's
funny that the chickens that we have in
chicken city are in like a truman show
and they have no idea that we eat them
and we're eating their eggs and they
just it's just oblivious and it makes me
wonder about our life and everything
that's going on in the world because
we're being treated they're treating us
like chickens you know they're lying to
us
they let our look i let the chickens do
their thing you know they they wake up
and they run around and they eat bugs
and and eat food and it's just there
it's a beautiful home they don't realize
that we are in control of their
existence and that's what i feel like
these these global elites and the world
economic forum types are doing to us
right now
just lying to us to control us and
they're like we don't care if they do a
podcast i don't care if the chickens
scream you know what i mean they don't
care if we do this you've all know
harari calls some people uh useless
eaters he's claiming there's like a
class of people that are considered
useless the useless class i don't think
he would consider you in the useless
class because you're actually
contributing you know emotional support
for society and things but a lot of
people that just get home from their
nine to five drink bud light and watch
sports it's like the use he considers
them relatively useless which is yeah
you know i don't personally they can do
a lot but you know if they're not doing
a lot
that potential is not connected wouldn't
the idea be that like someone who just
like consumes the products and does
their job actually they're very useful
because that's how you make your money
that's you're showing advertising too
no because a lot of these jobs are
useless and don't provide towards any
goal right
so
the view that these people have is you
are useless your job is useless and if
you weren't around it'd be better for
everybody and that's that's scary
prospect people want to put on the
metaverse on pharmaceutical psychedelics
that's what i think you've all know her
he's with the world economic forum he's
thinks that that's the future of the
useless classes they'll be put on like
pharma or sterilize sykes and in their
verse experiencing what they want to
experience
i'm sterilized but they'll be happy
about we're all they'll be completely
you look yeah yeah it's about keeping
them docile
when nora link becomes public these woke
cultists are going to be lining up
screaming and begging for it
that's it
they're going to be you know but yeah
and we'll see though if we get to that
point where we actually do get you know
computer brain interface working
because there's some difficulties with
it technology may not be around the
corner elon musk is trying he got
monkeys doing weird monkey stuff
would you sign up for it would you get
neuralink me no yeah but um there is an
interesting point about
right now the issue with neuralink
because it's like what is it read only
right yeah
right is where you get interested it
gets interesting
so i'll put it this way
if you could get a port attached to your
you know you know
brain stem or whatever
and it would probably be a magnet
wireless transmission i doubt it would
be like a plug that clicks in
but uh you you put it on the back your
neck and it writes to your brain and
then all of a sudden you're in lord of
the rings you're in die hard you're john
mcclane
everyone would want it
it would be that you'd be a literal
dream come true people would be like you
get to you mean i get to be the carrot
and then they go into a world where
their carrot they're just like running
around yelling like some people want
weird weird stuff man they'll be trying
to explain something to someone and the
person's like i don't get in there like
let me show you and then you see what
they're thinking and then it's going to
be like how do i compete i want to
interact with people like that i want to
show them what i'm feeling can i so i
got to get the plug this sounds
appealing to me tattoos yeah it does
doesn't it no it doesn't it doesn't have
a feeling to me this sounds horrifying i
feel like your brain is your own
personal space and to be like well but
if i give you a link you can come join
me here like no get out but it's not
even about that it's about
some guy goes to work at mcdonald's and
then he's just like he's making the
burger and he's like walking over who's
your burger sir thank you very much
here's your drink and then he goes home
and he's like huh he takes a thing
clicks it to his his neck and then i'll
say
i am valsanor hero of the fourth wind
and then he starts fighting dragons he's
gonna people are gonna beg for that
they're gonna line up and be like
i hate my life i want to be a rabbit and
then they're going to go into rabbit sim
and they're going to run around as a
rabbit and they're going to go into goat
simulator and then run around
head button people and things like that
or goose simulator remember goose yeah
that goose game that game was fun
headbutt simulator would be cool
and it's gonna be time dilation so
they'll be able to go in for what they
perceive as 20 hours and then when
they're done it's only an hour's gone by
somehow would you not want that ability
people are dude people are gonna go
visit loved ones who died it's gonna get
dark and but people are gonna beg for it
they're gonna be like in this simulated
world we've taken all of your father's
facebook posts compiled them into an ai
and now you can go and hang out at a
cafe for his birthday and you're gonna
go in and he's gonna be there and he's
being like you know i'm a robot but i'm
your dad and then you're going to be
like i missed your dad and it could be
to the point where anyone that resists
that could be seen as a terrorist to the
status quo like if you wanted to stop
people from getting embedded in that
system you're you're in the way of
what's right and what's good and you are
a danger to society like i can see
you're a religious zealot i mean the
thing is if you believe in liberty you
would let people sign up for it if they
want to be in it but ultimately every
time you come out of that simulation
you'll feel more depressed you'll hate
your life even more i think you would
hope that enough people want to invest
in the fact that they have a real life
that they can make whatever they want
out of it or they can go into pain
simulator and then when they come out
they're like well this isn't so bad yeah
but look at post-modernism people don't
believe in reality they don't believe in
objective reality they would rather live
you know what hey i say let them do it
in fact we should all agree let's all
the postmodernists how about we give you
guys neural link we hook you guys up put
you in the pods we'll make sure that pod
economy is working just fine for all you
because we don't want you coming out and
then we'll live our lives everything
will be fine and you get to live the
world you want to live in everybody
everything works we believe in objective
reality so we'll take objective reality
you take the pod universe and we'll uh
we'll we'll polish those pods nice and
clean all for you and uh and there you
go it works it works for me
finally
this is such a dark conversation yeah
because if you do put people in pods and
then kind of let them off on their own
it'd be like letting an ai figure out
how to wipe out humanity on its own if
you don't watch it and watch what it's
doing it can very well be working to
destroy you i feel like i've seen this
movie it's
it's interesting yeah i was just
thinking about terminator 2 last night i
don't really know
so but the issue with the matrix is it
shouldn't be robots to be people people
run the matrix and some people want to
be in the matrix and they choose to be
and what would really end up happening
or i think a probable scenario is that
if we actually built the metaverse you'd
have a lot of people and there'd be a
company and says we can hook you into
the metaverse permanently your body will
be suspended in a float solution we'll
take care of you to make sure there's no
injuries we'll keep you healthy and your
body will be regulated and the neural
link will actually stimulate muscle
growth and will provide you with a
feeding tube and in this universe you
will do work and that work will interact
with objective reality you can leave at
any time tons of people would sign up
for that and then what would you do in
the digital world coding
you know jobs related to the arts and
things like that and software
development
and just harvest
labor job you'd host a podcast and then
people in the real world listen to your
show and you're and you're just in a pod
floating there but your brain is
creating this simulation and you make
money from that and then you have to pay
the pod company a percentage of revenue
or a month a yearly fee of you know 20
grand or whatever to maintain the pod
for you
and you live in your own universe and
then in this universe let's say you host
a podcast and then the podcast is over
you stand up and you're like alright
guys thanks for coming everybody i'm
gonna go fight some dragons for the next
few hours and then fly away and then
like you know your guest is like i'm
gonna go be a dragon then turns into a
dragon and flies off that's the world
people are gonna want to live in and
they're gonna pay to do it and like your
super chat followers will be in your
party at the end of the night you're
like now i'm gonna fight dragons in like
the top four super chatters are gonna be
in the party with you fighting the
dragons tonight yeah you're gonna be
back if you super chat you're in the top
four you get to come fight dragons or
aliens or zombies or zombie alien
dragons whatever
i totally believe you that people will
pay for this and people will want it it
just personally sounds so unappealing to
me i believe so fundamentally that you
have this life to live and you have to
do something with it in this time like
deciding that you are going to it's like
as if you were not telling me i'm just
spending the rest of my life watching tv
like that's what i'm hearing when you
sign up for neurolink like you're just
looking to be distracted from the
reality of the world and if that's your
choice i respect it like i don't want to
tell people what to do but i think
ultimately you're lying to yourself if
you think you will ever be a more
satisfied person from
completely devoted post-modernists will
be maybe absolutely i don't think
they're very happy now but maybe well
they don't want they want they don't
want to be what they are
they're like there are people who want
to be cats
there are people who want to be animals
and they're people who want to be
cartoon animals they identify as these
things they would absolutely take the
neural link implant but it's better than
just watching tv like another it's like
if you were reading twitter all day and
then making an internet video show on
youtube at the end of the night like
kind of like exactly what tim does and
what i do see i mean the important thing
people need to understand right now is
that this show is actually produced in
the metaverse yeah like we're not real
we were i hate it here
hannah clare is actually a 30 year old
kidnapped
it's an interactive way to experience
humanity
but you're saying that you think power
off like just being out in the field is
better like what do you mean it's not
good
i mean i think fundamentally
it's a deception right you're you may
feel like you're fighting dragons you
may feel like you have a podcast and you
might have some kind of relationship
with someone who else is pretending to
be something it to me reminds me of the
criticism you get of social media right
that everyone is putting out a fake
front and that's why we tell people to
stop checking instagram and twitter all
the time because it's actually bad for
your mental health you know it'd be
really funny though if like it turned
out all of this is one weird metaverse
simulation for hannah clare who's
actually a 56 year old morbidly obese
man who's like i just want to be a young
blunt woman and so like you're sitting
here being like you're all crazy
metaverse is terrible but like it's
actually your simulation yeah i think if
i were to wake up and realize that i was
in the metaverse and that was true i
would be really miserable which means i
would go back into the matter right and
i think that's terrible like i think
giving people
you know we talked about earlier that
facebook intentionally tried to see if
they could make people depressed and
follow the content they produce
afterwards like that is what this is
opening the door to because what what is
the point of
not having you hooked up to the normal
link you're going to be on your deathbed
and your family's going to be around you
and they're going to be like we love you
nana and you're going to be like i lived
a good life and then all of a sudden
it's going to blink and you're going to
wake up as a 56 year old morbidly obese
guy you go
back to the salt mines and gotta go to
work but think of all the relationships
you would form in the metaverse that you
would think are real and then if
anything were to happen to your pod
they'd get deleted they're not real i
mean kind of but you know i don't lament
not hanging out with princess peach
after i beat mario so i had a friend
that did ayahuasca ceremony and he said
it was like a two-day ceremony and he
said he lived another life in this
ceremony like a like a psychedelic
experience where he had family a wife
and children that he remembers and still
to this day
misses like he knows them
that's why yeah dude i've heard a lot of
crazy stories like that dmt is crazy
i think just being told constantly that
like ev like even if you forget right
you're in the you're in the metaverse so
intensely and you're doing whatever
if it ever were to be over you would be
destroyed right and i think that's why
you have to live your real life and not
your fake life and if there are things
that you are
aspiring to be right like i can't help
you if you want to be a cartoon cat
maybe you should draw one and become a
cartoonist or go to the metaverse you
could be a cartoon chaos you know don't
go to the metaverse don't go you going
in matt i'm not going in yeah are you
gonna i'm i'm analog i i want to
actually live
the life i have so call me old school
will you work with the developers i
don't think it's old school
unless i can become a cat because that
sort of stuff you can yeah
in the metaverse you can be a kid i just
want to knock that's how they get you
they get it's going to be like drugs
they're going to be like just try it
once see what the encapsulation i just
want to knock stuff off the counter no
one will blame you for it
it's like all i've ever want to do is
climb up on someone's table and just
throw stuff on the floor scratch it you
could do that in your real life i just
want you to know now why did they do
that you know what i mean they're
dominant they do this thing where they
go to a door and then yell at you and
you open the door and they turn around
and walk away like they just want the
door open is that what it is
it's because cats are libertarians
you know what i love
i love it when they go up to a door and
they start yelling and then they'll like
put their paws under it and they're
shaking the door and yelling at you like
open it then you open it and they they
just walk off yeah i can't they just
don't want the door closed yeah keep it
open i had a cat who would like stand
there and scratch the door constantly
like he thought he could dig his way
through it you'd open the door and he'd
be like i don't even know why you did
that like i'm going the other way now
so uh bokus downstairs in the pantry
he's always screaming like to open the
door and you do and he immediately runs
to these loose kibbles that are on the
ground because he's a weirdo and he he's
tricking you he's it's a trick because
as soon as you walk away he jumps into
the box of bacon that's right i see him
do that and then he starts tearing the
bacon open eating all the bacon
and then when you so then when i caught
him doing it i picked him up and he's
yelling
one time it was really funny he was
trying to go in the garage and i kept
blocking his path and then he got really
mad and just went like this with his
hand real slow and then weft me one time
on the leg
and then i was like what are you doing
got it and then he just walked away i
went up behind him he was looking out
the window and i kind of roughly petted
him on his sides and he turned around
and swiped at my face with full claw
just got the hair but he was letting me
know i'm faster than you sharper than
you just don't mess with me just a shot
across about yeah and i've never touched
him that way yeah you're only supposed
to like go with the flow if they're
further fridays are the best watch
they're taking the important news
if they start flipping their tails
everybody lay off everybody can relate
to you know yeah my cats are
hardcore objectivists oh yeah but rourke
ragnar and reardon
and they absolutely believe that they
are superior of course and and frankly
they are
what's the hierarchy like over at the
kibby household um
they
they own everything and they eat better
than we do like when we're eating
crickets they're still going to be
eating the good beef
because that's the way it is but and by
the way like the the
the other half of this story and this
will upset some people listening dogs
are actually communists i don't know i
don't know if you can oh yes
yeah dogs are always looking for a
handout always looking for like
secondhand affirmation like a pat on the
head
my cats don't do that stuff yeah cats
are libertarian do you think that a pet
dog if faced with a pack of dogs that
wanted him to join would look at you in
the eye and be like sorry bro i'm going
like
i'm a communist at heart 100 ooh yeah
don't trust him yeah don't trust i want
to love dogs they look like psychopaths
when i look into their eyes i think
that's one of the reasons it's so dogs
are all right
it's so nice when a cat likes you
because like you don't have to whereas
dogs like they think you're in this
together and cats are like i'm choosing
this relationship with you you are lucky
to have my teacher cat gives you a
little bit of love but like it it's a
boost to your self-esteem yeah
finally i matter yeah yeah dogs are
clingy but i like dogs dogs you know i
like dogs because they're loyal they're
like loyal soldiers you know they're
there for you and like you're not going
to get your cats dude like you can never
train a cat to do anything they train
you can't even get bogus use a litter
box yeah piss it on the floor it's a
theory that the hats domesticated humans
back in the day that's how it all
happened it happened kind of
synergistically but a big part of it was
casual well watching people chill cats
are an invasive species that we
tolerated yeah one of the things i've
heard is like cats that's not true that
is incorrect they didn't meow they
started doing that to talk to humans
like that they they don't do this in the
wild and they do it for your benefit
which i think is hilarious dogs were
domesticated by humans and wolves slowly
being pushed together for mutual benefit
cats just hang out and people laugh
because they're funny and cats don't
bother us that's why they're they're
technically domesticated in that sense
but you don't you can train them but
they're not really tradable because we
did not like
livestock beasts of burden
all trained horses trained cats
sometimes people will train a cat
because you can but for the most part
they don't you can you can do some kind
of training with them but for the most
part because cats came into human
existence by like jumping through our
windows and then we laughed about it
not because they ate mice
uh terriers were bred for hunting mice
and rats
is there any way to get a cat a male cat
to stop peeing yes how diapers we have
diapers for him
there's nothing like that though he must
that must drive him he walks all funny
but if he's going to piss on the floor
give him a diaper and they make like
those those sprays that are supposed to
like tell your cat not to pee there and
stuff like that yeah but he's cat urine
you like have to soak the i don't know
why i'm giving this advice
but anyways
i had a really great cat he died just
about a year ago and i was obsessed with
him but he went whenever i like moved or
something he had a really hard time
adjusting with p places and you have to
clean with apple cider vinegar because
it's so the smell is so intense they can
go back to exactly the same spot thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there